I'm Katz eASIC I'm the director of a
short history of the high-rise it's an
interactive documentary that traces the
history of vertical living
when the New York Times approached us at
the National Film Board of Canada to
collaborate potentially collaborate they
told us about this place called the
morgue it's a collection of photographs
that are Undead and you know three
floors below Times Square and I thought
that that would be such a fascinating
way to revisit the history of
essentially how our cities have been
built over time my name is Jeff Roth I
work in what's called the morgue at the
New York Times I kind of manage all the
old stuff it's called the morgue that's
kind of a reporter's parlance for where
all the dead stories Lyerly it was
created back in 1905 by our legendary
managing editor carve Anand and to start
codifying and creating a clippings
library as far as what is down here well
first thing is the clippings collection
dates back to the 1870s there's the
picture library and so that comprises oh
we estimate maybe between 6 and 8
million physical photographs I would
estimate only 1 to 2 percent is
digitized which means 98 to 99 percent
are not digitized there's always a
serendipity of finding something that is
odd or is you know quite historically
valuable oh yeah tell me a little bit
about these um pictures from London and
Russia and all that oh yeah so these are
I mean this is just you know London
housing and then it would be Russia
housing and this I spent about a week in
the morgue it's this incredible
collection of forgotten history the back
of the photographs tell a whole story I
mean it's it tells all the contextual
stuff so it tells you you know when the
photo was published it tells you maybe
the cut line it can tell you what part
of the paper it was published in this is
a great folder I just found another gem
I mean I know you're not surprised but
when I stumbled
this beautiful photograph of the
majestic building sitting you know like
a crown on top of Central Park
I immediately knew that that would be
the opening shot of the entire series
what's cool about our process is that I
really didn't know what the film would
be until I spent time with the material
in the morgue so I didn't come in with a
preconceived notion which is for me a
real documentary process
nothing beats getting lost in a
collection of 6 million photographs and
finding your way out with a really
fascinating story